an unprovoked invasion of ukraine
which nato and the whole world condemn
this is the worst military aggression in
europe for decades
with the cities under siege
schools
hospitals
and residential buildings shelled
reckless actions around a nuclear
power plant last night
and many civilians killed or wounded
the days to come
are likely to be worse
with more death
more suffering
and more destruction
as the russian armed forces
bring in heavier
weaponry
and continue their attacks
across the country
at our meeting today
ukrainian foreign minister coleba
addressed his nato counterparts
and allies expressed their solidarity
and deep respect
for the courage of the ukrainian people
and armed forces
we had warned for many once months that
president putin was intent on invading
ukraine
that is why nato allies made tireless
efforts to find a diplomatic solution
at the same time we made clear that
russia would pay a very high price
for renewed aggression against ukraine
russia is paying that price now
this is
president putin's war
one he has chosen
planned
and is waging against a peaceful
country we call on president putin to
stop this war
immediately
we draw all
his forces from ukraine
without conditions
and engage in genuine diploma diplomacy
now
nato allies have stepped up support for
ukraine
helping to uphold
the country's right
of self-defense
as enshrined in the u.n charter
today ministers addressed our immediate
response to the crisis
and the longer term implications for
europeanic security
we have already strengthened our
deterrence on defense
on land
in the air and at sea
allies from north america and europe
have sent thousands more troops to the
eastern part of the alliance
we are deploying the nato response force
for the first time
and we have over 130 yets at high alert
and over 200 ships from the high north
to the mediterranean
we will continue to do what it takes to
protect and defend every inch of nato
territory
nato is a defensive alliance
our core task is to keep
our 30 nations
safe
we are not part of this conflict
and we have a responsibility to ensure
it does not escalate and spread beyond
ukraine
because
that would be even more devastating and
more dangerous
with even more human suffering
nato is not seeking a war with russia
the kremlin's ambition is to recreate a
sphere of influence
and deny other countries the right to
choose their own path
so ministers discuss the need to support
partners who may be at risk
including georgia and bosnia-herzegovina
russia's aggression has created a new
normal for our security
where fundamental principles are
contested through the use of force
and we face the threat of conflict for
years to come
there is much at stake
how we organize relations between states
whether democracy or authoritarianism
prevails
and ultimately what sort of world we
want to live in
ministers agreed that nato's
relationship with russia has
fundamentally changed for the longer
term
but we remain committed to keeping
chance for diplomacy and the confliction
open
to avoid any unintended escalation
misunderstanding or miscalculation
there is one lesson we can already draw
from this crisis
to keep our nation safe we need north
america and europe standing together in
nato in strategic solidarity
at this dangerous moment no country and
no continent can go it alone
president putin has failed to divide us
nato is more united more determined and
stronger than ever
we're also working
closer with like-minded partners today
we were joined by the european union as
well as finland and sweden
in response to russia's aggression we
have decided to strengthen our
coordination and information sharing
with finland and sweden
both countries are now taking part in
all nato consultations about the crisis
and this afternoon i will join a meeting
of eu foreign ministers to address the
crisis
and our response